[Music]
alright ready 1 2 3
holy crap that was a lot of people how
awesome is that
yesterday I was speaking in front of all
those boarders managers thanks for
participating by the way but today I
don't have anything to do at all so I
thought I'd just walk around Denver it
sure is beautiful here although
unfortunately the city is being attacked
by a giant bear first I ran into this
guy his job seems kind of redundant then
because it's important to me to
appreciate local cuisine I went and had
lunch at Chili's - I'm telling you man
this town is being attacked by giant
metal bears then I found myself at ESPN
Zone and I thought maybe they have
nerdfighters they didn't have
nerdfighters
but they sure had boxing and horse
racing ah boy horse racing is one of
those things that feels a lot cooler
than it looks
ESPN's own might not be the fastest way
to spend $10 but it's the fastest way
I've ever encountered
then I happened to cross a mall Hank I
haven't been to a mall in like ten years
so I decided to do an anthropological
experiment and see how much malls have
changed in the decade that I've been
away faux marble tile check Sunglasses
Hut check nobody needs a shoeshine check
Panda Express check subway check flag
world check sorry it broke on the way
home by the way low quality merchandise
at high quality merchandise prices check
card store where you don't want to buy
any of the cards check now I know what
you're wondering Hank you're wondering
well sure they still have card stores
but do they still sell the same items
that they did 10 years ago
check and now you're saying okay fine
they still sell Thai stuffed animals but
do they still sell those glass etching
's that are extraordinarily cheesy but
sometimes convey true sentiments
check I missed the Yeti gourmet gumballs
check GNC check wait wait wait go back
gourmet gumballs gourmet gumballs what
kind of flavors you got chocolate
milkshake creamsicle banana strawberry
nerds gum nerd gum rock hey in short
according to my anthropological
experiment the American mall remains
largely unchanged from what it was ten
years ago the primary difference it's
just a little more awesome mmm nerdy
Hank I'll see you tomorrow